it was nice really good blog I think
it's a good episode actually because
it's a good episode that speaks to not
everything always working out right
tonight I was planning to do three four
five hours of live selling a shitload of
books but then between some family stuff
and the team and then we decided I was
gonna go to office and I've been in like
just didn't just six didn't work out
then we met at a pizza shop where I
thought I could do it but then Wi-Fi
didn't work I couldn't go live so we
just had a little impromptu kind of
one-hour meeting
iris Alex Tyler Tyler Andy Andy Rock and
I like it's so black and white obvious
we're gonna be we're gonna cry we're
gonna like sit here in three years when
there's nothing like it I'm gonna be
like dude what them and then we came out
here we drew the brunch out of a bucket
on the street the person that is joining
us for brunch on Monday the 26th is and
that's it like just mission not
accomplished which is okay
just gotta get punched in the mouth and
move on to tomorrow just did not
accomplish what I wanted but I'm unfazed
by it and I think you know I'm not such
a roll we we haven't had an opportunity
to share those kind of moments I think
it will help a lot of you because a lot
of feels like one doesn't it work out
well didn't work out today did not work
out tonight did not work out tomorrow
morrow I'm good we did find another
dumpster they [ __ ] suck they're sweet
[ __ ] trash that's why I [ __ ] found
a dumpster we didn't find another
dumpster keep that high school trash
back in high school
[Music]